quienes somos
y es lo que queremos ser y qué es lo que
nos define como personas esos son
algunos de los factores que la identidad
tiene dentro de sí nos ayuda nos ayudan
a diferenciar entre nuestra identidad
social y nuestra identidad personal
estos son los dos factores que yo más
cuando era más joven creí que eran todo
lo que significaba identidad es decir el
del lado social ok que comunidades soy a
las que formo parte que religiones que
ideales y actualmente han sido muy bien
defendidas a hemos visto que hay
progreso en el mundo del lado de la
comunidad del lado de la sociedad la
gente tiene más derechos vamos bien del
lado de lo personal nuestros sueños
nuestras orientaciones nuestros
modelos a seguir nuestro cuerpo es
respetado y está seguro hay una manera
de comprobarlo nosotros por ejemplo
hagamos un ejemplo conmigo mismo aquí
tengo yo ciertas de las cosas que me
distinguen
frente a los demás no dentro de una
comunidad por ejemplo yo soy formó parte
élites universidades de cita de
guadalajara soy miembro de la iglesia
católica una de las sagas favoritas que
tengo es el señor de los anillos' me
encanta la fantasía la magia la ciencia
ficción tengo un grupo muy divertido de
amigos y me encanta la música
electrónica además de eso soy fan número
del 9 del ramin para mí es como el amor
estomacal lo adoro
pero no solo son estas dos partes el
lado social y el lado personal lo que
forman mi identidad y lo descubrí de una
manera bastante desafortunada para
hablarles de mí tengo que decirles que
una persona que tiene bastante mala
suerte soy una persona muy precavida
porque sé que siempre se me olvida algo
siempre que me toca hablar en público
este para que trabajo o a veces me toca
de que se me olvida la llave de donde
voy tengo que entrar o lo que sea ahora
en este caso yo les voy a hablar de mi
experiencia en el chapala water festival
este es un festival de música
electrónica está en guadalajara bueno
más bien está en chapala es el lago de
agua dulce más grande de méxico las
clases de geografía pero lo interesante
aquí es que está una obra y cachito de
mi casa su casa
y he decidido ir con mi mejor amigo a
este lugar somos fanáticos de la música
electrónica un parque semiacuático va a
ver juegos de agua orales vámonos ahora
lo interesante es que cuando vamos
llegando a este lugar me dicen amigo
sabes quebró nada más baja te tu boleto
del lugar y tu dinero
todo lo demás déjalo es un lugar donde
va a haber agua se te puede caer del
pantalón se le pueden pedir prestado
evitarte una pena no baja está bien
amigo si te voy a hacer caso no voy a
revelar su nombre porque me lo quiere
tomar porque lo quiero mucho pero de
todos modos lo interesante es que pasa
el tiempo dan las nueve y media de la
noche y no lo encuentro empiezo a
preguntar a la gente que nos ubica vaya
pues por él saben el reggaeton este y me
toca es saber que se fue a guadalajara
me dejó ahí
y ver qué hago que sigue pues bueno
pidiendo ride afuera porque obviamente
ya después de que vas a buscar el
estacionamiento ves que el carro no está
y te dice el guardia de seguridad nueva
joven sabe que ella no tiene el boleto
no pueden traer chispas
ahora común como un burrito mínimo para
que se me baje no no traigo mi tarjeta
no traigo mi celular para marcarle un
nuevo ver zona muy millennial ya sé pero
quiero llegar a un punto con esto qué
pasa cuando no es gracioso
qué pasa cuando tu abuelo no te puede
acompañar a navidad porque pierde su
pasaporte
qué pasa cuando tus amigos no pueden ir
a cumplir con su examen de la carrera
porque no tienen la tarjeta que avala
que están en esa universidad cuánta
gente no ha perdido un examen que es un
parteaguas en la vida de un joven con
una simple identificación otro me tocó
de hecho en ciudad de méxico no traes tu
licencia se te olvidó porque traía spam
se sabía flojo de y no
una multa está entre 7 150 a 1.500 pesos
por no traer tu licencia un simple
plastiquito que avala que sabes manejar
jefe me encontró en el carro vea estoy
manejando
qué pasa cuando la vida está en juego
en california el año pasado y de hecho
este año ya están igual de bravos han
habido infiernos e infiernos en donde se
pierden casas en donde se pierde ganado
en 12 donde se ha perdido hectáreas de
árboles y es para mí muy doloroso
comentar que hay una persona que se tuvo
que despedir de su familia por celular
debido a que no le pudo decir a su
máquina a su automóvil automóvil tú eres
mío
enciende enciende sácame de aquí
entonces
esta tercera parte de la identidad de
las que les platico es la identidad
institucionalizada la identidad
gubernamental la identidad hecha por la
industria esto es lo que ellos creen que
somos recuerdan al principio cuando les
enseñé mi foto y la de mi familia de mis
completas en ningún momento les dije que
yo me veo como un plástico bueno nada
más por el peso ya no somos iguales no
me veo como una llave entonces
qué es lo que podemos hacer para
eliminar estos identificadores físicos y
sacarlos de nuestra vida qué es lo que
se nos puede ocurrir para hacer algo al
respecto para independizarnos de toda
esa bolsa todos esos llaves y todos esos
identificadores y demás
nosotros pensamos en la idea de crear
una identidad global en la que pueda ser
el nexo el núcleo de todos esos objetos
ahora cuál es el secreto el secreto está
en cada uno de ustedes en su adn si
ustedes se voltean a ver unos a los
otros
descubrirán que no hay una persona que
sea exactamente igual dicen los gemelos
o no yo sé negativo dentro de su adn
dentro de su estructura de cómo están
hechos son diferentes ahora muy
interesante porque al analizar nosotros
que biometría íbamos a utilizar para que
se convirtiera en esta nueva red de
identidad biométrica este núcleo de
identidad tuvimos que ir tachando varios
factores número uno tiene que ser una
identidad teniendo en cuenta que va a
ser una identidad que va a manejar
dinero propiedades identificación
personal posiblemente ante gobierno
tenemos que agarrar una que sea lo
suficientemente simple y segura y sobre
todo enfocada en la privacidad y el
consentimiento de la persona porque
porque queremos evitar lo que sus que
sucedan las cosas que suceden en china
en hong kong las protestas que están
habiendo la gente ya no quiere salir a
la calle ya no quiere consumir
porque ellos tenían esta idea de hacer
la biometría facial que es exterior que
es externa al cuerpo que ustedes pueden
ver mi cara con eso están monitoreando a
las personas siguen monitoreando las y
lo interesante es que el siguiente
mercado y nosotros lo sabemos es
latinoamérica
esto es un tema muy importante porque
nosotros lo que estamos proveyendo es
una idea en donde tú seas tú seas libre
y no tengas que estar siendo grabado
todo el tiempo nosotros lo único que
necesitamos es privacidad y
consentimiento privacidad porque
cumplimos con las reglas biométricas más
avanzadas en cuanto a los derechos de
uso de los datos personales es decir tú
eres el único que puede acceder a tu
información número 1 y número 2 requiere
nuestra solución interacción
huella dactilar reconocimiento facial
reconocimiento del iris todas son
externas al cuerpo esas pueden ser
copiadas la facial hoy ya tengo yo con
que me estén grabando mi celular cuando
digo pan de chocolate y que me salga el
chocolate saben así ha anunciado en la
primera página de instagram por favor no
entonces lo que nosotros creamos es una
identidad que le la estructura penal
interna de la palma de la mano son cinco
millones de puntos que nosotros
recopilamos dentro de esta arquitectura
penal que lo que hacemos es encriptar la
guardarla en una bóveda y se convierte
en la única llave para que para poder
sustituir tarjetas llaves
foxx y más
y en nosotros consecuentemente podemos
hacer con un simple escaneo sin contacto
de la palma de la mano podemos abrir
puertas podemos pagar
podemos canjear boletos podemos comprar
cosas podemos tener recompensas y todo
con la palma entonces ya no sabe ya nos
acabamos a todos los identificadores
bolsas de fendi bolsas para bolsos gucci
tiemblen porque se va a acabar esa
dependencia de esas bolsas
ahora muy interesante porque las capas
de identidad que puede generar este esta
tecnología hacen algo que se llama
prueba de vida déjenme les platico que
uno de los principales temas que a los
bancos y a las industrias grandes a los
grandes de la industria más bien es oiga
joven y si me corto en la mano
híjole pero es una realidad y es la
realidad por la que ha tenido tanto
éxito esta idea nosotros en nuestras
capas de identidad al ofrecer esta
prueba de vida nos referimos a que tiene
ciertas características esta vena está
estar arbolito de venas que tenemos
dentro número 1 son venas des oxigenadas
son venas que ya fueron pasadas por el
corazón es decir vena arterial sabemos
que la avena es cuando ya la sangre está
es oxigenar pero también es importante
porque tenemos presión en nuestras venas
tenemos calor y además movimiento dentro
de ellas al nosotros perder la mano
perdemos esa presión perdemos ese
movimiento perdemos ese calor y ya no
está pasando esa sangre por dentro de
las venas por lo tanto digamos que es
anti zombis y además
combatiente del crimen así que le
estamos quitando chamba a batman
esta es una pequeña muy grande gráfica
en donde demostramos el a comparación de
otras biometrías y estamos cuatro veces
por debajo de todas ellas en cuanto a
falsa aceptación y falso rechazo por lo
que nos convierte en la mejor opción
biométrica ahora es lo único que nos
diferencia estos numeritos que están
mencionando enrique no ahí les va muy
interesante porque qué es lo que podemos
llegar a lograr en las industrias
nosotros somos simples debido a que en
menos de un segundo
ustedes tienen un escaneo y en ese
momento les arroja quiénes son ustedes
entonces imagínense lo que podemos
llegar a lograr en los hospitales en
hospitales dijo lo que me dio el patatús
señor pib y ya de volada le avienta al
historial médico de la persona hay este
no manches tengo mi bebé hoy pero qué
tipo de sangre señor a ver la tenemos
preparar el registro listo ahora hoy es
que en mi farmacia de confianza en mi
boticaria el doctor chapatín no tiene
me escribe antibiótico a un antibiótico
ve pipí y nadie se tiene que andar
preocupando por una receta médica ahora
en el tema de movilidad es también muy
interesante porque cuántas veces no
hemos visto en facebook cuántas veces no
hemos visto en el internet que esté
asaltan a gente en los camiones que hay
problemas en los en los metros en los
autobuses etcétera con este tipo de
identificación verdad podemos hacer
boletos y podemos hacer accesos para el
camión para que lo que uno llegue el
maleante a la hora que quiera agencia
con el dinero
no traemos nada entonces les motivamos a
los malos y yo padre no ahora está el
otro tema que es el de seguridad muy
fregón porque ahí les va en las minas ya
saben que han habido ciertos accidentes
necesitamos saber cuánta gente está
dentro cuánta gente está afuera tenemos
también los autobuses que llevan a
nuestros niños bueno yo todavía no se
crean pero este pero que llevan a
nuestros niños y podemos tener la
seguridad de que al hacer el check-in al
hacer el escaneo el niño está dentro del
camión
el minero está dentro de la fábrica digo
perdón adentro de la mina y al check out
ya está afuera y se lleva un control
minucioso y ximo que puede llegar a
salvar vidas ahora está también el tema
de los bancos imagínense llegar a la atm
para que la mano no entonces lo padre de
esto es que podemos hacer estos pagos
con la mano podemos hacer transferencias
conscientes y además evitamos que se
pierda muchísimo dinero en fraudes de
identidad como lo menciona el banco en
méxico el banco en méxico dice que somos
la octava nación en la escala de un
millón de naciones obviamente somos la
nación esté en el nivel de crímenes por
fraude y robo de identidad
entonces yo a mí me gustaría que ustedes
hoy se fueran pensando
todos esos procesos todas las
actividades que llevan al día a día en
el que ustedes han tenido un dolor de
cabeza por no contar con uno de estos
identificadores porque porque al final
de cuentas lo que queremos nosotros
lograr es que las bolsas de sus
pantalones sólo sirvan para calentar las
manos y que al final del día se a
calentar esas manos para su próximo
escaneo
a gracias que estén muy bien